bonjour et j'ai une question pour
commencer est ce que vous aimez marcher
les marchés sur de grandes distances
alors personnellement j'aime marcher
mais sur 250 km sur des centaines de
kilomètres beaucoup moins nous avons ici
comme dans tous les pays nous avons des
organisations sportives nous avons des
des événements sportifs dont par exemple
du trail qui est une qui est un concours
en fait les des str qui s'étale sur
environ 146 kilomètres et qui fonctionne
par étape pendant la parfaite état
appartient km ensuite 12 km le prend fin
ça fonctionne par état et je m'étais dit
que si moi je n'aime pas marcher mais
qu'on forçait à faire c'est 140 mille
kilos ces 146 km je pense que je
mettrais énormément de temps pour le
faire et par contre si je devais le
faire pour une raison qui me passionne
ou pour une cause qui me tient à coeur
comme par exemple pour ma fille pour des
personnes que j'aime je pense que je
ferai ça avec plus de vitalité et donc
peut-être que ma performance serait
beaucoup plus intéressante une autre
question est ce que vous êtes déjà
tombés amoureux je pense que ça c'est
une question à laquelle tout le monde
plus ou moins peut répondre oui même si
même si au moment actuel la situation
amoureuse n'est pas forcément au top et
je pose cette question parce que
j'aimerais que vous reveniez à ces
moments où vous êtes senti amoureux et
que vous pensiez en fait à ses exploits
que vous avez accompli pendant ces
périodes où l'émotion vous portez et je
voudrais que vous revenir un peu sur ses
sensations ses ressentis et puisque vous
vous étiez dit à l'époque est ce qu'à un
moment vous vous êtes pas dit mais je ne
me pensais pas capable de réaliser tout
ça personnellement j'ai marché sous la
pluie en pleine nuit sur plusieurs
kilomètres pour rejoindre mon chéri de
l'époque et je n'ai alyscamps fait
l'amour fait faire ses miracles alors on
n'est pas ici pour parler d'amour
évidemment n'ai parlé ici on est ici
pardon pour parler de performance
et de performance dans une dimension un
petit peu plus
irrationnel je dirais puisque
aujourd'hui tout est processes et tout
est standardisée tout est cadré on
essaie de rationaliser un peu tout les
choses pourquoi et bien simplement pour
la bonne marche de l'organisation
d'entreprise ça serait vraiment
compliqué c'est tout le monde parle et
partait dans son sens ça serait
difficile à cadrer
maintenant la question est et si
finalement le management et la
performance ne tenait qu'à des aspects
irrationnels
ou plutôt et si la performance reposait
beaucoup plus sur une dimension
irrationnelle plus rationnelle ce que ça
vous ferait sourire je sais que une
grande majorité de chefs d'entreprise
serait contre pourtant tout le monde y
penser sérieusement si aujourd'hui la
définition de la compétence telle
qu'elle est qui inclut donc le savoir
les connaissances tout ce que vous avez
acquis pas nécessairement les diplômés
tout ce que vous avez appris à qui mise
à jour au fil du temps ça c'est le
savoir
ensuite dans le concept de compétence on
a également le savoir-faire donc votre
capacité à exécuter techniquement une
tâche par exemple cadreur qui c'est ça
qui fait son travail depuis des dizaines
d'années et qui sait exactement à quel
moment de quelle manière comme en
illimité les choses c'est du savoir
faire c'est une capacité d'exécution
technique est aujourd'hui le concept de
compétences aujourd'hui depuis une
dizaine depuis quelques dizaines
d'années inclut également ce qu'on
appelle le savoir être donc cette
capacité a entre guillemets avoir une
certaine attitude aujourd'hui la
compétence ne se définit et ne se
conjugue avec ce triptyque savoirs
savoir-faire et savoir-être et si nous
sommes d'accord que le savoir faire est
assez cadré c'est à dire qu'il y a des
indications très précises très standard
en fait pour un poste même si parfois ça
peut déborder débordé il peut y avoir
des bases le savoir peut être lui aussi
plus ou moins cadrée si je veux être
cadreur je dois donc avoir des
connaissances qui sont liées à ce
médecin cadreur donc pouvoir prendre des
ans l'avoir d'émotion des couleurs etc
aujourd'hui on essaye également de cadre
et de standardiser ce qu'on appelle le
savoir être et on essaye de lui limité
donc aujourd'hui la notion de la
compétente est limité puisque on limite
en fait le savoir être également à ce
qu'on appelle les aptitudes et le
comportement ce qui est radicalement
faux puisqu'on parle bien de savoir être
et non de savoir se comporter savoir se
comporter dans un contexte précis peut
être rationalisée savoir-être ne peut
pas être rationalisés et si le mot être
justement à une définition qui va bien
au delà du comportement bien au delà de
l'attitude puisque un comportement pour
rappel un comportement est une
succession d'actions et d'attitudes
qu'on a en fait acquis par habitude dans
une situation donnée ou dans des
contextes données
savoir-être va bien au delà d'un
je parle de cette dimension
irrationnelle tout simplement parce que
tous autant que nous sommes
dans un contexte professionnel
nous avons pu nous épanouir et nous
avons pu dépasser nos limites grâce à
une dimension irrationnelle je
m'explique
aujourd'hui il est de plus en plus
courant dans les entreprises d'avoir des
cadres d'avoir des horaires on a même
des entreprises
mon type les entrées
on essaie de cadres et de rationaliser
de baliser en fait les choses et on
exige en plus donc des salariés qu'ils
soient performants
mais quand on comprend le fonctionnement
du cerveau humain et quand on comprend
le fonctionnement de la nature humaine
celle inverse de c'est tout l'inversé de
ce qu'on devrait faire et attention je
n'essaie pas de me positionner ici en
expert en
en neurosciences puisque ce que j de
toutes les manières et très largement
documenté qu'il s'agisse des
neurosciences ou des sciences
managériale ou des sciences cognitives
tout simplement je sais juste
d'expliquer une chose qui est basique et
qui est rempli de bon sens
posez vous la question le moment de
votre vie où vous avez été le plus
performant est ce que ces moments de
performance ont été dictées par des
cadres très précis avec une ambiance
très strictes et très sévère ou est-ce
que ça a plus étaient dictés par des
mouvements des émotions interne qui
permettait justement de libérer ce qu'on
appelle des hormones a mis les hommes en
année il y en a un grand paquet mais
plus communes sont d ocytocine la
sérotonine la dopamine
l'endorphine etc on ne va pas discuter
on va pas les détails et est ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que parmi ces armes
en a par exemple la dopamine qui est
leur manque de la récompense qui est
cette cette hormone qui se libère à ce
moment savez où vous ressentez une
certaine
satisfaction d'avoir accompli quelque
chose à quoi servent ces harmonies
alors ces hormones pour schématiser je
dirais c'est amon sont un peu comme on
va dire que le corps humain pour faire
court le corps humain va dire que c'est
une banque qui est et que dans ce corps
on a accès normalement on devrait avoir
accès à des milliers de comptes
bancaires qui sont donc régie par des
gestionnaires de comptes dans des
moments dans des environnements de
travail
stricte sévère cadres et où l'ambiance
est plus à l'autorité ou à la
supériorité et où on vient travailler
par obligation on vient travailler par
contrainte pour un salaire pour par
sécurité etc pour des raisons sociales
ou d'évolution sociale tout simplement
alors dans ces moments de stress de
contraint d'obligations il ya
certainement des hormones a mis encore
une fois mais
les amendes qui prédomine qui sont plus
libérés sont les hormones du stress qui
est on à l'adrénaline mais surtout on a
le cortisol et je vais pas m'étaler sur
ce que produit le cortisol ou nelly mis
sur les effets qu'il peut avoir sur le
corps par contre ce que je peux dire
c'est que les effets du cortisol sur les
capacités cognitives sont assez
intéressantes pourquoi parce qu'elle les
limites tout simplement elles peuvent
les booster à une certaine d'une
certaine façon mais quand ces hormones
sont libérés de manière trop pétales et
ou de manière répétitive à la longue au
niveau cognitif parce que c'est le nivet
qui nous intéresse quand on parle de
performances au niveau cognitif on
atteint certaines limites on atteint des
limites au niveau de la concentration le
cerveau est beaucoup moins oxygéné on a
du mal à prendre des capacités on add on
du mal à prendre des décisions
pertinentes
on a du mal à s'organiser et la liste
est extrêmement êtes vous sûr que c'est
ce que vous voulez vraiment
produire comme effet auprès de votre
équipe êtes vous sûr que c'est vraiment
la manière dont vous voulez que vos
équipes fonctionnent et perform et si l
inverse
dans un environnement professionnel
on a on va dire un contexte beaucoup
plus accueillant beaucoup plus
enrichissant ou les personnes viennent
travailler parce qu'elles ont envie et
parce qu'elles ont trouvé un sens à ce
moment là les hormones qui se libèrent
sont d'autres hormones ce sont les
hormones ni dont je vous parlais et l'
avantage de ces hommes en a mis pour
revenir aux comptes bancaires et bien
ses hommes annie elle ouvre la porte de
toutes nos ressources c'est à dire qu'on
a enfin accès à toutes les ressources
dont on a besoin qu'ils peuvent être
cognitives toutes nos ressources
internes mais également externes donc ça
peut être ça peut être de la motivation
ça peut être de la créativité ça peut
être de la réflexion ça peut être toutes
les formes de ressources qu'on a pour
pouvoir performer
donc pour faire court l'idéal quand on
veut parler de performance et plus de
libérer ces hormones and i est d'essayer
de limiter les hormones pas forcément et
demi puisque l on observe aussi mais le
cortisol essentiellement donc l'harmonie
du stress il est plus conseiller
recommandé de limiter comment on fait ça
et bien aujourd'hui on a dans certaines
grandes entreprises qui ont plus ou
moins compris comment ça se passe on a
ce qu'on appelle les tifs happiness
officiels sont des personnes qui sont
supposés s'occuper du bien-être des
équipes au travail sauf que c'est bien
de mettre des tables de ping pong au
travail c'est bien d'installer des
salons et des caméras c'est bien voilà
de mettre une ambiance où des journées à
thèmes ou des journées festives mais
dans le fond est ce que c'est réellement
efficace c'est bien organisé des team
building de dépenser des budgets
faramineux pour organiser des journées
on se retrouve mais est-ce qu'au bout du
bout ça apporte tellement les impacts
qu'on cherche en termes de cohésion
termes d'organisation terme de
motivation et si le plus simple au fond
était de réorganiser tout l'esprit même
du travail est de faire reposer la
performance sur cette dimension
irrationnelle qui et
quand je dis rationnelle ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elle n'est pas validée par la
science au contraire elle est validée
par la science puisqu'aujourd'hui on a
réussi à mettre en place au niveau de
mih
un cycle en fait d'engagement qui
commence par impliqués si aujourd'hui au
lieu de dépenser des budgets faramineux
dans des organisations de bien-être qui
n'apporte pas nécessairement les
résultats escomptés si au lieu de ça on
commençait par impliquer l'équipe c'est
à dire les faire entrer dans l'histoire
c'est à dire leur demander de participer
à la construction de la société en leur
parlant de manière respectueuse et
surtout responsable si on les valorise
et 2e et à valoriser c'est à dire
reconnaître ce qu'ils apportent
reconnaître leur apport
reconnaître leurs capacités avec leurs
limites mais surtout reconnaître ce
qu'ils apportent si on les
responsabiliser troisième étape c'est à
dire leur pousser à réfléchir par
eux-mêmes à développer le sens de
l'initiative et comme quand une personne
en général est impliqué elle devient
plus ou moins responsable c'est à dire
que c'est son business aussi et que donc
elle apprend a assuré assumer également
des conséquences des décisions qu'elle
prend je parlais de responsabiliser
parce que trop souvent aujourd'hui à
tous les niveaux on a
un manager management trop infantilisant
c'est à dire il nous faut faire si il
nous faut faire ça vous devriez on
devrait alors que le langage devrait
être un petit peu différent plus
responsabilisant quand on se tue qu'est
ce que tu penses à porter comment le
ferais tu comment pourrais-tu quelles
suggestions apporterez dessus et c'est
donc non seulement qui implique mais qui
responsabilise et à ce moment là la
personne finit par être beau se sentir
responsable plus ou moins naturellement
et fini par assumer d'une certaine
manière également les conséquences plus
facilement en tout cas les conséquences
des décisions qu'elle peut prendre et
proposait donc nous avions je le disais
impliqué valoriser responsabiliser nous
avons également la quatrième étape qui
est important puisque nous sommes
humains que parfois avec le stress et
les urgences nous pouvons également
avoir une certaine certaines limites
donc c'est bien de responsabiliser une
équipe c'est bien la valoriser mais
parfois quand elle déborde il est
important de recadrer mais à ces moments
là seulement c'est à dire l'inversé la
proportion de recadrage par rapport à ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir sur terrain
où il ya énormément de recadrage la
proportion de recadrage est important
alors qu'elle devrait être beaucoup plus
limité et la cinquième étape qui est
répétée puisque dans tout processus de
changement de transition ou
d'apprentissage
la répétition est la base de tout de
l'efficacité de ces transitions
donc voilà si on essayait de penser les
choses un petit peu autrement sont
nécessairement dépenser beaucoup de
budget je pense que les résultats et
surtout beaucoup plus positif pour tout
le monde beaucoup moins de stress pour
les supérieurs beaucoup plus d'entrain
une motivation et d'engagement pour les
collaborateurs et au final beaucoup plus
de rentabilité beaucoup plus d'impact
même si c'est vrai qu'à ce niveau là les
impacts parce que ce sont des impacts ne
font pas nécessairement tangible
immédiatement ils seront il reste
tangible en tout cas d'une certaine
manière sur le thème est ce que nous
avons vu sur terrain c'est que ça marche
c'est que ça marche c'est que c'est
satisfaisant et c'est que c'est surtout
très rentable voilà peut-être que il est
temps aujourd'hui de repenser le
management c'est la performance de cette
manière et après tout c'est pas si
compliqué sa demande juste en fait un
changement d'une réappropriation
certains paradigmes de manager oh et une
réappropriation de certains état
d'esprit qui sont dans tous les cas de
figure basées sur le bon sens voilà
après tout la performance n'est donc pas
si compliqué que ça atteindre puisque la
performance et multidimensionnel elle
concerne tous les aspects d'une
entreprise mais elle est donc passif
elle n'est finalement donc pas si
difficile à atteindre que cela ait
finalement pas si coûteuse au contraire
je dirais même assez rentable